הפותר הווריאציוני הקוונטי של ערכים עצמיים, או VQE, הוא אחד האלגוריתמים ההיברידיים הקוונטיים-קלאסיים הראשונים והוא
מעניין מכמה סיבות. ראשית, כפי שנראה בסרטון הזה, זו גישה מבטיחה לסוגים מסוימים של בעיות. שנית, הוא חשוב
מבחינה היסטורית וסלל את הדרך לאלגוריתמים משופרים רבים כמו adapt VQE.
ולבסוף, VQE הוא די פשוט. קל להבין מה המחשב הקוונטי והקלאסי עושים באלגוריתם הזה
ואיך הם מתקשרים ביניהם. יש ארבעה מרכיבים עיקריים בחישוב VQE.
ראשית, יש אופרטור, לרוב המילטוניאן, שנקרא לו H, שמתאר תכונה של המערכת
שאתה רוצה לייעל. דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאתה מחפש את הווקטור העצמי של האופרטור הזה
שמתאים לערך העצמי המינימלי. לרוב קוראים לווקטור העצמי הזה מצב היסוד.
הבא, יש אנזאץ, מילה שמשמעותה גישה. זהו circuit קוונטי שמכין מצב קוונטי שמקרב
את הווקטור העצמי שאתה מחפש. למעשה, האנזאץ הוא משפחה של circuits קוונטיים כי חלק מה-gates
באנזאץ הם פרמטריים. כלומר, הם מקבלים פרמטר שאנחנו יכולים לשנות. המשפחה הזו של circuits קוונטיים
יכולה להכין משפחה של מצבים קוונטיים שמקרבים את מצב היסוד.
הבא, אנחנו צריכים אסטימטור, אמצעי להערכת ערך הציפייה של האופרטור H על פני המצב הווריאציוני
הקוונטי הנוכחי. לפעמים מה שבאמת מעניין אותנו הוא פשוט ערך הציפייה הזה, שאנחנו
קוראים לו פונקציית עלות. פעמים אחרות אכפת לנו מפונקציה מסובכת יותר שעדיין אפשר לכתוב החל מ-
ערך ציפייה אחד או יותר.
לבסוף, אנחנו צריכים אופטימייזר קלאסי, אלגוריתם שמשנה פרמטרים כדי לנסות למזער את פונקציית העלות.
בואו נתאר את הבעיה שאנחנו רוצים לפתור ואת הגישה הכללית לפני שנתייחס לתפקיד של הקוונטום. אנחנו
יכולים להציג הרבה בעיות אופטימיזציה קריטיות למדע ולתעשייה כבעיות ערכים עצמיים של מטריצות. בדרך כלל, אתה
רוצה את הערך העצמי המינימלי של המטריצה שלך ואת הווקטור העצמי שמתאים לו. המטריצה H יכולה להיות
המילטוניאן שמתאר את האנרגיה של מערכת פיזיקלית. והערך העצמי המינימלי יהיה אנרגיית מצב היסוד
E0 והווקטור העצמי יהיה מצב היסוד הקוונטי המתאים שמסומן לרוב פסי 0.
או שהמטריצה יכולה לתאר פונקציית עלות מסובכת שקשורה לבעיות אופטימיזציה קומבינטורית
כמו בלוגיסטיקה והמצב העצמי s אופטימלי יהיה פתרון אופטימלי של
הבעיה כמו מחרוזת בינארית שמסמנת חתך בגרף של רשת חלוקה. בפועל
נפוץ לשמוע את המונח המילטוניאן לכל המטריצות המעניינות גם מחוץ למדעים הפיזיקליים. נגיד
שאנחנו מתעניינים במטריצה עם n שורות ו-n עמודות. בעיות כאלה אפשר לפתור מהר ובדיוק באמצעות
פותרים קלאסיים עבור n עד כמה מאות או אלפים בלי הנחות על המטריצה. עבור מטריצות דלילות,
כאלה שרוב הערכים שלהן הם אפסים, זה יכול להיות הרבה יותר גדול עם n עד מיליארד אפילו על מחשב נייד.
אבל עבור בעיות ענקיות באמת שחורגות מהמספרים האלה, לרוב צריך שיטות קירוב או היוריסטיות.
ככל שהמטריצה גדולה יותר ופחות דלילה, הבעיה פחות פתירה וצריך להפעיל יותר טריקים חכמים. נניח שהמטריצה שלך כל כך
גדולה שלכסון מדויק הוא לא אופציה. נניח עוד שאתה יודע מספיק על הבעיה שלך כדי
לעשות כמה ניחושים על המבנה הכללי של מצב המטרה ואתה רוצה לבדוק מצבים דומים לניחוש
הראשוני שלך כדי לראות אם העלות או האנרגיה שלך יכולות לרדת עוד. זו גישה ווריאציונית וזו שיטה אחת
שמשתמשים בה כשלכסון מדויק לא אפשרי במחשב קלאסי. זה עובד ככה.
ראשית, אתה עושה מצב ניחוש עם כמה פרמטרים תטא שאתה תשנה.
למרות שהניחוש הראשוני יכול להיות אקראי, זה לא מומלץ. אנחנו רוצים להשתמש בידע על הבעיה הנוכחית
כדי להתאים את הניחוש שלנו כמה שאפשר.
שנית, נחשב את ערך הציפייה של האופרטור כשהמערכת במצב הזה.
שלישית, נשנה את הפרמטרים הווריאציוניים ונחזור על התהליך.
רביעית, נשתמש במידע שנצבר על הנוף של מצבים אפשריים בתת-המרחב הווריאציוני שלך כדי לעשות ניחושים טובים יותר ויותר
ולהתקרב למצב המטרה.
העיקרון הווריאציוני מבטיח שהמצב הווריאציוני שלנו לא יכול לתת ערך עצמי נמוך יותר מזה של
מצב היסוד המטרה. אז ככל שערך הציפייה נמוך יותר, כך הקירוב שלנו למצב היסוד טוב יותר. בואו
נדבר על הקושי של כל שלב בגישה הזו.
הגדרה או עדכון של פרמטרים היא קלה חישובית. הקושי שם הוא בבחירת פרמטרים ראשוניים שימושיים עם
מוטיבציה פיזיקלית. שימוש במידע שנצבר מאיטרציות קודמות לעדכון פרמטרים בצורה
שמתקרבת למצב היסוד הוא לא טריוויאלי. אבל קיימים אלגוריתמי אופטימיזציה קלאסיים שעושים
את זה די ביעילות. האופטימיזציה הקלאסית הזו יקרה רק כי היא עשויה לדרוש הרבה
איטרציות. במקרה הגרוע, מספר האיטרציות עשוי לגדול באופן אקספוננציאלי עם n.
השלב היחיד הכי יקר חישובית הוא כמעט בוודאות ערך הציפייה של המטריצה שלך באמצעות
מצב נתון. המטריצה n כפול n חייבת לפעול על הווקטור בן n האלמנטים מה שמתאים לסדר גודל של n בריבוע
פעולות כפל במקרה הגרוע. זה חייב להיעשות בכל איטרציה של פרמטרים. עבור מטריצות
גדולות במיוחד, לזה יש עלות חישובית גבוהה. עכשיו תדמיין שמעבירים את החלק הזה של
החישוב למחשב קוונטי. במקום לחשב את ערך הציפייה הזה, אתה מעריך אותו על ידי הכנת
המצב s של תטא על המחשב הקוונטי באמצעות האנזאץ הווריאציוני שלך ואז ביצוע מדידות.
בואו נפרק את זה קצת. H הוא בדרך כלל לא קל למדידה. לדוגמה, הוא יכול להיות מורכב מהרבה
אופרטורי פאולי X, Y ו-Z שלא מתחלפים.
אבל אפשר לכתוב את H כצירוף ליניארי של איברים H אלפא שכל אחד מהם קל למדידה. לדוגמה,
אופרטורי פאולי או קבוצות של אופרטורי פאולי שמתחלפים ביט-ויז. ערך
הציפייה של H על פני המצב S הוא הסכום המשוקלל של ערכי הציפייה של האיברים המרכיבים H אלפא.
הביטוי הזה נכון לכל מצב s אבל אנחנו ספציפית נשתמש בו עם המצב הווריאציוני שלנו s של תטא.
כל אחד מהאיברים h אלפא אפשר למדוד m פעמים מה שנותן דגימות מדידה s אלפא j כש-j רץ מ-
1 עד m ומחזיר ערך ציפייה וסטיית תקן. אנחנו יכולים לסכום
את האיברים האלה ולהפיץ שגיאות דרך הסכום.
זה לא דורש כפל בקנה מידה גדול ולא שום תהליך שבהכרח גדל כמו n בריבוע. במקום זאת,
זה דורש מדידות מרובות על המחשב הקוונטי. אם אתה לא צריך יותר מדי מהן, הגישה הזו יכולה להיות
יעילה. וזה החלק הקוונטי של VQE. אבל בואו נדבר על סיבות למה זה עלול לא להיות יעיל. סיבה אחת
למדידות רבות היא להפחית את אי-הוודאות הסטטיסטית בהערכות שלך לחישובים ברמת דיוק גבוהה
מאוד. סיבה נוספת היא מספר מחרוזות הפאולי הנדרשות לכסות את כל המטריצה שלך. כי מטריצות פאולי ועוד
היחידה פורשות את המרחב של כל האופרטורים בממד נתון, מובטח לנו
שאפשר לכתוב את המטריצה המעניינת שלנו כסכום משוקלל של אופרטורי פאולי כמו שעשינו קודם. כאן C אלפא הוא
מקדם מספרי ו-H אלפא הוא מחרוזת של אופרטורי פאולי שפועלים על כל ה-qubits שמתארים את המערכת שלך.
H אלפא יהיה בצורה כזו כשאופרטור הפאולי ה-n מימין פועל על ה-qubit ה-n. אז אנחנו יכולים
למדוד את האופרטור שלנו על ידי מדידת סדרה של אופרטורי פאולי. אבל אנחנו לא יכולים למדוד את כל אופרטורי הפאולי האלה
בו-זמנית. אופרטורי פאולי לא כולל היחידה לא מתחלפים זה עם זה אם הם
משויכים לאותו qubit. לדוגמה, אפשר למדוד I Z IIZ ו-ZZ
XZ בו-זמנית כי אפשר למדוד I ו-Z בו-זמנית עבור ה-qubit השלישי.
ואפשר לדעת I ו-X בו-זמנית עבור ה-qubit הראשון. אבל אי אפשר
למדוד כל Z ו-Z ZZ ZX בו-זמנית כי Z ו-X לא
מתחלפים ושניהם פועלים על ה-qubit האפסי.
אז אנחנו מפרקים את המטריצה H לסכום של פאולי שפועלים על qubits שונים.
חלק מהאיברים בסכום הזה אפשר למדוד בבת אחת. קוראים לזה קבוצה של פאולי מתחלפים. תלוי
בכמה איברים לא מתחלפים יש, ייתכן שנצטרך הרבה קבוצות כאלה. נקרא למספר הקבוצות האלה של פאולי מתחלפים
T.
אם NGCP קטן, זה יכול לעבוד טוב.
אם ל-H יש מיליוני קבוצות, זה לא יהיה שימושי. אתה מתעד את ערך הציפייה או את פונקציית העלות
עבור סט הפרמטרים תטא שנמצא בשימוש במצב שלך ואז אתה מעדכן את הפרמטרים לאורך זמן. אתה יכול להשתמש
בערכי הציפייה או ערכי פונקציית העלות שהערכת כדי לקרב גרדיאנט של פונקציית העלות שלך בתת-
המרחב של מצבים שנדגמו על ידי האנזאץ שלך.
קיימים אופטימייזרים קלאסיים מבוססי גרדיאנט וגם חופשיים מגרדיאנט. לשניהם יש בעיות פוטנציאליות של אימון כמו
מינימומים מקומיים מרובים ואזורים גדולים במרחב הפרמטרים עם גרדיאנט קרוב לאפס שנקראים רמות שוממות.
אז האם VQE יפתור את כל הבעיות הקשות ביותר שלך? לא. אבל להיות טוב יותר בכל החישובים מעולם לא היה המטרה. אנחנו
שינינו את מה שקובע את העלות החישובית. תסתכל במה החלפנו. עברנו מתהליך
שהמורכבות שלו תלויה רק בממד המטריצה לתהליך שתלוי ברמת הדיוק הנדרשת ובמספר
אופרטורי הפאולי הלא מתחלפים שמרכיבים את המטריצה. לחלק האחרון אין מקבילה בחישוב קלאסי.
בהתבסס על התלויות החדשות האלה, עבור מטריצות דלילות או מטריצות עם מעט מחרוזות פאולי לא מתחלפות, התהליך
הזה עשוי להיות שימושי. זה המצב עבור מערכות של ספינים מקיימי אינטראקציה. לדוגמה, עבור מטריצות צפופות, זה עשוי להיות
פחות שימושי. אנחנו יודעים, לדוגמה, שלמערכות כימיות יש לרוב המילטוניאנים שכוללים מאות, אלפים, ואפילו
מיליוני מחרוזות פאולי. נעשתה עבודה מעניינת לצמצום מספר האיברים האלה, אבל
מערכות כימיות עשויות להתאים יותר לחלק מהאלגוריתמים האחרים שנדון בהם בקורס הזה.
שימוש יעיל ב-VQE דורש גם שנכיר תכונות של מצב המטרה שלנו ונוכל לבחור מצב ראשוני טוב עם
מוטיבציה פיזיקלית וגם אנזאץ טוב עם מעט יחסית פרמטרים ווריאציוניים. זה יכול להיות
די מאתגר. VQE מדגים איך אפשר לשלב את החוזקות של מחשבים קלאסיים וקוונטיים
בלי להוסיף שיטות חדשות יותר. VQE לא עוזר לנו לפתור בעיות שהן בלתי פתירות למחשבים קלאסיים, אבל
הוא ממשיך למלא תפקיד בפיתוח אלגוריתמים. ו-VQE גם מלמד אותנו שהעברת שלב ממחשבים קלאסיים
למחשבים קוונטיים היא לא טובה יותר ולא גרועה יותר לכל מטרה. אלא, היא
משנה אילו גורמים קובעים את היעילות של האלגוריתם שלך. זהו שיעור כללי חשוב בחישוב
היברידי קוונטי-קלאסי.